like how would you describe suge as a
person
based on your relationship with nothing
as as everybody think he is
he's just a big old cool [ __ ] to me he
one of the coolest names i ever met
because we hear all this crazy [ __ ] and
then you hear people who like really
know him and they're like man
is one of the realest like one of the
realest coolest [ __ ]
one of the i mean the stories he'll tell
you you feel me to even sit
sit in a circle and listen to these
stories he'll tell you and it's just
like yeah
so after after watching after knowing
him and then watching all these
[ __ ] weird-ass shits that they got on
tv about
tupac and biggie and shook this and
shook that i'd be like damn that's
they just got the whole [ __ ] on top of
suga it's just like
yeah there's all this they drag his name
through the mud like that you know i
feel like
in that situation with the tupac biggie
situation obviously both of them dying
there had to be you got to you got to
figure out who the bad guy is and the
public
made suge the bad guy in this yeah yeah
because
because there was nobody there i mean
look both both murders are still inside
the angel exactly they made puffy angel
but now it's coming out like he was
really
on the same type of [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying like some of this [ __ ] man
it's like damn [ __ ] 25 years later like
you was on the same
type of [ __ ] you got crips with you i
just found that out like
you had to come to trips with you bro
like you knew what you was doing like
come on man
yes some of the uh stuff that ca like i
remember there was an la times article
that came out about puffy maybe like
eight nine years ago and it was like
oh yeah you talking you popping [ __ ]
again we don't
again we don't know i mean at least i
don't know
yeah i mean there's people who think
they know exactly what happened
on each side right yeah but it's it's
interesting i mean i'm not
sure that was definitely the bad guy
yeah yeah sugar was paying as the bad
guy
and made it seem like [ __ ] was
bullying puffy and biggie and [ __ ] like
that but